Biba Struja was in high school in Serbia when he learned he was different from other people.
当Biba Struja在塞尔维亚读高中时，他发现自己与众不同。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
[非英语发言]。
We talked about it through an interpreter. He was on the phone from Serbia. He said it was a rainy day. They were going in to weld gates and fences. And his friend touched the fence they were working on and got a shock.
我们通过翻译和他进行了交谈，他当时正从塞尔维亚打来电话。他说那是个下雨天，他们正要去焊接大门和栅栏。他的朋友碰到了正在施工的栅栏，结果触电了。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
[非英语发言]。
He told me not to touch anything because there was electricity there. But I touched it with my bare hand, and I didn't feel anything. Nothing happened.
他告诉我也别碰任何东西，因为那里有电。但我用赤手碰了碰，什么感觉都没有。什么也没发生。
Nothing happened.
什么也没发生。
So he didn't believe me that I didn't feel anything, that there was no electricity in the fence. So he touched it again, but he was shocked again.
所以他不相信我没感觉到什么，也不相信栅栏上没电。于是他又碰了一下，结果又被电到了。
Then another guy touches the fence, and he was shocked. Biba sees this, and he thinks, oh, it's a prank. They're pretending.
接着另一个人也碰了栅栏，也被电到了。Biba看到这一幕，心想，哦，这是恶作剧，他们是在装模作样。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
[非英语发言]。
So I touched the fence with both hands again, and I didn't feel anything. And we started fighting. I didn't believe them, and they thought that I was lying.
所以我又用双手去碰栅栏，还是什么感觉都没有。于是我们吵了起来。我不相信他们，而他们认为我在撒谎。
Biba has a genetic mutation where he doesn't sweat. That means his skin has a lot less water and so a higher resistance to electricity. He says he does not feel currents that would shock most of us. And scientists say, yeah, that might be possible. This super power does come with that huge downside of not sweating, ever. Having a body that cannot cool itself is really, really miserable.
Biba患有一种基因突变，导致他不会出汗。这意味着他的皮肤水分含量极低，因此对电流的电阻更高。他说他感觉不到大多数人会感到触电的电流。科学家们表示，是的，这确实有可能。这种超能力确实伴随着一个巨大的负面影响，那就是永远无法出汗。拥有一个无法自我降温的身体真的是一件非常非常痛苦的事。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语发言]
From May until September, I'm a dead man, basically.
从五月到九月，我基本上就像个死人。
Because of the heat.
因为太热了。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
[非英语发言]。
Yes. I need to be next to an air conditioner all day, or I need to be in a wet t-shirt or next to water or something.
是的，我整天都得待在空调旁边，或者必须穿着湿T恤，或者是待在水边之类的。
But the biggest problem with having a special talent like a high resistance to electricity is figuring out what exactly you do with that talent. You can't just put on a costume and join the X-Men. Until the day that mankind is threatened by an alien race whose bodies are electric charges, you really aren't much use as a superhero. Biba's brother has the same genetic mutation, and he decided to do nothing with it. He stayed on the family farm.
但是拥有高电阻这种特殊天赋，最大的问题在于搞清楚到底该怎么利用它。你不能随随便便穿上一套戏服就加入X战警。除非有一天人类受到外星种族的威胁，而这些外星人的身体带电，否则作为超级英雄，你真的没什么用。Biba的兄弟也有同样的基因突变，他决定不去利用它，而是留在了自家的农场里。
But Biba was sure there must be a way to monetize this. So he went into show business, created a little act doing electricity tricks, like this one-- he sticks a fork in each end of a hot dog, holds the hot dog in midair in front of his face, one hand on each fork, and then-- OK, it's not clear exactly what's going on or whether you actually need a genetic mutation to do this trick, but electricity is pumped through the forks and cooks the hot dog.
但Biba确信一定有办法把这变现。于是他投身演艺圈，创造了一个小节目，表演电击技巧，比如这个——他把叉子插在热狗的两端，把热狗悬空放在脸前，每只手拿着一个叉子，然后——好吧，到底发生了什么，或者做这个特技是否真的需要基因突变，目前还不清楚，但电流通过叉子把热狗煮熟了。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
[非英语发言]。
This is from a really good film that was made about Biba called Battery Man, Biba saying, am I the fastest grill or not? It just takes a minute or so to cook a hot dog this way. He toured around Europe doing this act, mostly in discos, he says, sometimes on TV. It's not much of a living. He's got kids. So he supplements that with a job that also sounds like it's kind of a grind for him-- he does therapeutic massages with electricity, up to 20 a day.
这段视频出自一部关于Biba的优秀纪录片，片名叫《电池人》。Biba当时在说，我是不是最快的烧烤架？用这种方式煮熟一个热狗只需要一分钟左右。他在欧洲各地巡回表演这个节目，大多是在迪斯科舞厅，他说有时也会上电视。这赚不了多少钱。他还要养孩子，所以他靠一份听起来对他来说也像是一种苦差事的工作来补贴家用——他用电做理疗按摩，一天最多做20次。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
[非英语发言]。
I have a certificate as an electrobiotherapist.
我拥有生物电疗师的证书。
In English, anyway, this word "electrobiotherapist" has the unusual distinction of producing not one hit when you Google it. Mostly, you're probably getting the picture-- Biba's special talent does not seem to make him very happy. When we talked, he complained about the injustice of being born in Serbia, where people don't understand his special gift. In the movie about him, he says sometimes his talent feels like a curse. But when I asked him about that, he said, we're all cursed.
总之，在英语中，“生物电疗师”这个词有个不同寻常的地方：你在谷歌上搜索它，竟然找不到任何相关内容。总之，你大概已经看出来了——Biba的特殊天赋似乎并没有让他感到快乐。我们交谈时，他抱怨出生在塞尔维亚的不公，那里的人们不理解他的特殊天赋。在关于他的电影里，他说有时他的天赋感觉像是一种诅咒。但当我问他时，他说，我们都是被诅咒的。
All of us on this planet are in some kind of jail, doing time here. It just depends how long. It depends on the punishment you get, how long you're on this planet.
我们星球上的所有人都在某种监狱里服刑，只是时间长短不同。这取决于你受到的惩罚，取决于你在地球上待多久。
That's what having a talent like this does to you. You end up saying stuff like that. It seems sometimes like our entire culture is about glorifying people who have incredible special abilities. We have superhero films. We have magazine articles on inspiringly great musicians and writers, then tech billionaires who invent whole new kinds of businesses.
拥有这样的天赋就会让你变成这样。你最终会说出这种话。有时看来，我们的整个文化似乎都在崇拜那些拥有不可思议特殊能力的人。我们有超级英雄电影。我们有关于励志音乐家和作家的杂志文章，还有发明全新商业模式的科技亿万富翁。
Today, we are not going to be talking about those people. For once, let us look at the less fortunate super-talented-- and by that I mean people who are gifted, but gifted with skills that just don't help anyone that much. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, "My Undesirable Talent." Stay with us.
今天，我们不谈论那些人。这一次，让我们关注一下那些不那么幸运的天才——我的意思是，那些有天赋的人，但这些天赋对任何人都没有太大帮助。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。今天我们的节目主题是“我那令人尴尬的天赋”。请继续收听。
Act one, "Climb Spree." So we begin today with a man whose special skill was in the criminal arts. Is that a phrase? Like, I said that, suddenly it felt very Hogwarts School. Anyway, I'm trying to say he had a real gift for committing crimes. Karen Duffin explains.
第一幕，“犯罪狂欢”。所以，今天我们从一个特殊技能在于犯罪艺术的人开始。这是个正经说法吗？就像我刚才说的那样，感觉非常有霍格沃茨魔法学校的味道。总之，我想说的是，他确实有犯罪天赋。Karen Duffin来为大家解释。
Lou Bronfeld was a cop in San Francisco for 42 years. He spent 16 of those in the burglary unit. And when he talks about his most memorable cases, there's the one where two teenagers stole koalas from the zoo to impress their girlfriends, and there was a series of remarkable burglaries that all happened in the spring of 2002. They all fit the same pattern.
Lou Bronfeld在旧金山当了42年警察，其中16年在盗窃部门工作。当他谈到自己最难忘的案件时，有一个是两名青少年为了给女友留下深刻印象而从动物园偷走了考拉，还有一个就是2002年春天发生的一系列引人注目的连环入室盗窃案。它们都符合同样的模式。
The suspect would get into a variety of businesses at night via a skylight or the loft or the attic and then lowering themselves down in some of these businesses, and would take the valuables, and then raise themselves back up, almost like right out of a James Bond movie.
犯罪嫌疑人会在夜间通过天窗、阁楼或顶楼进入各种企业，然后潜入这些店铺窃取贵重物品，接着再原路返回，简直就像詹姆斯·邦德电影里的情节。
He appeared to be a career criminal, often left no trace. Businesses sometimes didn't even know they'd been burglarized until they opened the safe or cash register. But it wasn't just his methods. It was the volume. Within a month, he'd pulled off dozens of burglaries.
他看起来像是个惯犯，经常不留任何痕迹。有些企业甚至直到打开保险箱或收银机时，才知道自己被盗了。但这不仅仅是手法问题，还有案件数量。在一个月内，他实施了数十起盗窃案。
You know, we're asking ourselves at work, how is this guy pulling this off? He must be something. I mean, he must be Spider-Man.
你知道，我们在单位都在问自己，这家伙到底是怎么做到的？他一定有什么过人之处。我的意思是，他肯定是蜘蛛侠。
They assigned more cops later at night to the neighborhood Spider-Man mostly hit. It took two months to catch him. But in those two months, he'd done 63 burglaries. Lou thinks it was the largest burglary count ever charged by the San Francisco DA's office. Spider-Man had done so much so unusually and in such little time the cops were anxious to finally meet him. They had a sense for who he'd probably be.
后来，他们在夜间安排了更多警力巡逻蜘蛛侠最常作案的街区。他们花了两个月时间才抓住他。但在那两个月里，他竟然犯下了63起盗窃案。Lou认为这是旧金山地方检察官办公室起诉过的盗窃案数量最多的一次。蜘蛛侠在如此短的时间内以如此不同寻常的方式做了这么多事，警察们都很想见见他本人。他们对他可能是什么样的人有种预感。
Really heavily addicted to a narcotic or he's criminally sophisticated, maybe on parole with a lot of priors. We meet this guy, and he didn't fit any of that.
要么是毒瘾非常深，要么是犯罪手段老练，可能正处于假释期且有许多前科。我们见到这家伙时，他完全不符合这些特征。
The guy had no prior arrests, didn't appear criminally sophisticated at all-- rather, a little naive. Lou says he was a gentleman-- quiet, polite, seemed relieved to have been caught. They had a hard time connecting the Spider-Man in their heads with the person in front of them, which is a feeling I understand.
他没有任何犯罪记录，看起来一点也不老练，反而还有点天真。Lou说他是个绅士——安静、礼貌，似乎被抓到反而让他松了一口气。他们很难把脑海中的那个“蜘蛛侠”与眼前这个人联系起来，这种感觉我深有体会。
Spider-Man is a friend of mine. During his crime spree, we knew each other from church. I was Mormon at the time. He still is. The idea that the guy who sat next to me singing "Choose the Right When a Choice Is Placed Before You" was going out every night and lowering himself into stores on ropes? How did that make any sense at all?
蜘蛛侠是我的朋友。在他疯狂作案期间，我们是在教会认识的。我当时是摩门教徒，他现在也是。那个坐在我旁边唱着“当选择摆在你面前时，要选择正确”的人，竟然每天晚上都在用绳子把自己吊进商店里？这到底是怎么回事？
You were, like, last on the list of people I would peg for this, you know?
在你会怀疑的人名单中，你肯定把他排在最后，对吧？
Yeah. Everyone was surprised. I was a missionary for my church just over a year before this or so. Like, a year and a half before this. It was the furthest thing from everyone's mind.
是的，大家都感到很惊讶。就在这事发生的一年多前，大约一年半前，我还去我的教会当过传教士。这是每个人最意想不到的事。
Yeah.
是啊。
I know everyone always says, I didn't see it coming. But nobody who knew him saw it coming. He's super capable in this effortless way-- cooking, singing, dancing, sports. If he wasn't so nice, it'd be easy to hate him for it, which is to say, it just felt so unnecessary. He had so many ways to make money. Why would he steal it? He was so well dressed, so perfectly put together, that the one clue his best friend Juliann spotted that something might be wrong was this--
我知道每个人总是说，我没想到会这样。但认识他的人里确实没人预料到。他能力超强，而且毫不费力——做饭、唱歌、跳舞、体育样样精通。如果他不是那么好相处，大家很容易因此嫉妒他，这简直是没必要的折腾。他有那么多赚钱的方法，为什么偏偏要偷呢？他总是穿得非常考究，收拾得整整齐齐，所以他最好的朋友Juliann发现不对劲的唯一线索是这个——
I noticed that he had dirt under his fingernails. And I asked him about it because it was very uncharacteristic of him.
我注意到他的指甲缝里有泥土。我问他原因，因为这对他来说非常反常。
She was alarmed because he had dirt under his fingernails. At church, people called him the guy with the Italian shoes.
她很惊恐，因为他的指甲缝里有泥。在教会里，大家叫他“穿意大利皮鞋的那个人”。
He's extremely detailed. He's more put together than most people feel like they need to be. Even when he was living in his car, he would have his clothes dry-cleaned.
他非常注重细节。他比大多数人对自己外表的要求都要高得多。即使在他住车里的时候，他也会把衣服送到干洗店。
He doesn't want to use his name here on the radio, so we thought we'd call him Peter Parker, or maybe Peter Parkour, since that's his MO. He proposed Peter Park. Sounds more Korean, he said, which he is. We decided to go with just Peter.
他不想在广播里用他的真名，所以我们想叫他Peter Parker，或者Peter Parkour，因为那是他的作案风格。他提议叫Peter Park。他说听起来更像韩裔名字，他也确实是韩裔。我们决定就叫他Peter。
Hey.
嘿。
Hi.
你好。
I'm on the second floor.
我在二楼。
OK, cool.
好的，酷。
I've been friends with Peter for 15 years. And all that time, my understanding of him has had this gap, like a blurry patch on a photo, when it comes to Spider-Man. There are so many things I've wondered and just never asked. Now, I'd finally get my chance.
我和Peter做朋友15年了。在那段时间里，对于他变成“蜘蛛侠”这件事，我对他了解的过程一直有个缺口，就像照片上模糊的一块。有很多事情我一直很好奇，但从未问过。现在，我终于有机会了。
Hey.
嘿。
Hi.
你好。
Hi!
你好！
This is so beautiful!
这儿真漂亮！
Thanks.
谢谢。
We're in his apartment in San Francisco-- floor-to-ceiling windows, open kitchen, great neighborhood. He works in sales now, makes good money, has a girlfriend. Peter and I talked for hours. And even before this conversation, I knew he became Spider-Man because he had a gambling problem and wanted money for it. But I had no idea how extreme his gambling was.
我们在他位于旧金山的公寓里——落地窗、开放式厨房、绝佳的街区。他现在做销售，收入不错，还有个女朋友。Peter和我聊了好几个小时。其实在这次谈话之前，我就知道他之所以成为蜘蛛侠是因为他有赌博问题，想弄点钱。但我根本不知道他的赌瘾有多严重。
A week before he left for college, he lost his entire college fund, thousands of dollars. In his early 20s, he was going to the casino almost every day, losing every last penny.
去大学报到前一周，他输光了所有的大学学费，好几千美元。二十出头的时候，他几乎每天都去赌场，输得一干二净。
My whole mindset was what am I gonna eat? How will I pay my rent? Can I still put gas in the car to get to the casino? That became a baseline necessity for me.
我的脑子里只有：我吃什么？我怎么付房租？我还能往车里加油去赌场吗？那成了我生存的基本需求。
Food, water, gambling.
食物、水、赌博。
Food, water, gambling. And food and water went away. At least I still had gambling. If shelter went away, at least I'd still have gambling. That honestly became the center and the focus of my life.
食物、水、赌博。而食物和水都没了，至少我还有赌博。即使没地方住，至少我还有赌博。老实说，那成了我生活的核心和焦点。
Of course, lots of people have gambling problems, and lots of people resort to stealing to feed that addiction. But lots of people do not embark on crime sprees so spectacular the cops give them a superhero nickname.
当然，很多人都有赌博问题，很多人会为了满足这种瘾而诉诸盗窃。但很少有人会去策划一场如此壮观的“犯罪狂欢”，以至于警察给了他一个超级英雄的外号。
Peter explains what happened this way-- he found himself penniless and weeks behind on rent. One night, he was closing up at the health club where he worked, and he went to transfer the cash to the safe like every night. But that night, he thought, oh, I could just borrow this, gamble it, win enough to pay back my landlord, and then replace it by morning.
Peter是这样解释发生的事情的——他发现自己身无分文，房租也拖欠了几周。一天晚上，他在工作的健身房关门，像往常一样准备把现金存入保险箱。但那天晚上他想，哦，我可以直接借用这些钱，去赌博赢够钱还给房东，然后再在早上把钱换回去。
And so I took it out before I put the money in the safe, and took $200 to the casino, and promptly lost it. So that night, I walked out of the casino thinking, am I going to jail?
于是我在把钱存进保险箱之前把它拿了出来，带着200美元去了赌场，结果很快就输光了。所以那天晚上，我走出赌场时心想，我是不是要坐牢了？
For taking the $200.
为了那偷来的200美元。
That was a big turning point. So I was driving home, probably around 2:00 AM. The bridge was really empty, and I'm thinking, do I jump off the bridge and just end this now? Or can I figure out a way of scraping together $200? How can I do that?
那是一个重大的转折点。当时大约凌晨两点，我开车回家。桥上空荡荡的，我心想，我是不是该跳下去一了百了？还是我能想办法凑到200美元？我该怎么做？
So I started-- I don't know how the idea entered my head. But Mission Impossible came to mind, the scene of Tom Cruise entering from the rooftop and being lowered down on some ropes.
于是我开始——我不知道这个念头是怎么冒出来的。但我脑子里蹦出了《碟中谍》，汤姆·克鲁斯从屋顶进入并用绳子降下来的那一幕。
And then he remembered this concession stand at his school, the City College of San Francisco. He'd bought snacks there. It's remote, probably easy to break into. He also remembered that when he worked at a restaurant, they didn't lock the safe. He hoped the concession stand didn't, either.
接着他想起了他所在的旧金山市立大学有一个小卖部。他以前在那儿买过零食。那里很偏僻，应该很容易闯入。他还记得以前在餐厅打工时，他们的保险箱是不上锁的。他希望那个小卖部也是这样。
And so I went home, got dressed in dark clothes, grabbed mittens because I didn't have any gloves. So I was wearing these-- basically like snowboarding mittens.
所以我就回家，穿上深色衣服，抓了副连指手套，因为我没有手套。所以我戴着那些——基本上就像滑雪用的连指手套。
Like without fingers?
就是没有手指的那种？
No fingers. No fingers. Just mittens.
没有手指，没有手指。就是连指手套。
Are you nervous? Are you excited? Are you scared?
你紧张吗？兴奋吗？害怕吗？
Oh, I'm incredibly nervous. Never done anything like this. This idea has never crossed my mind, to do anything of this nature.
哦，我紧张得要死。以前从来没做过这种事。做这种事的念头从来没在我脑海里出现过。
Honestly, I haven't been back here since that burglary.
老实说，从那次入室盗窃之后，我就没再回过那里。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Wow.
哇。
We're driving up to the concession stand.
我们正开车前往那个小卖部。
We're looking down into the stadium. And so just ahead of us now is this concession stand. We can probably just pull over right in front of this thing.
我们正俯视体育场。就在我们前面，就是那个小卖部。我们大概可以直接停在它面前。
It's a one-story building, maybe 15 by 15, fully concrete with a rolling window in front where vendors hand out hot dogs and beers during games.
那是一栋单层建筑，大约15乘15英尺，全混凝土结构，正面有一个卷帘窗，比赛期间小贩就是从这里递出热狗和啤酒。
And I had always been a really good climber, climbed tons of trees as a kid and always loved climbing things. So I thought, I can probably find a way to climb on top of this building.
我一直是个很擅长爬高的人，小时候爬过无数棵树，而且一直喜欢爬来爬去。所以我心想，我大概能找到办法爬到这栋建筑的顶上。
He did. He found a hatch on top, like a skylight, but it's steel. He turned the handle. It was unlocked. He opened it, and he dropped 10 feet into the darkness. No rope, just jumped. Had no idea what he was dropping into. He'd never been in there before. Pretty soon, bingo.
他做到了。他在顶上发现了一个舱口，像个天窗，但是钢制的。他转动把手，锁没锁。他打开舱口，跳进十英尺下的黑暗中。没有绳子，直接跳。他根本不知道自己跳进了什么地方，以前从未进去过。很快，宾果。
There was the safe. And it was open. And there was $5,500 in cash and coins. And so I bundled it all up, and I took the sweater off that I had brought. I hadn't brought a backpack with me. Poor planning. Took my mittens off so that I could actually grab all the money, bundled all of the money up in the sweater that I kind of tied the sleeves of the sweater together. And my heart was pumping out of my chest.
保险箱就在那里，而且是开着的。里面有5500美元的现金和硬币。于是我把钱一股脑儿全塞了进去，脱下了我带来的毛衣。我没带背包，计划得很不周。我脱下手套以便能真正抓牢所有的钱，把钱都包在毛衣里，把毛衣袖子系在一起。我的心跳快得要从胸腔里跳出来了。
He climbed on a table and out the hatch, drove straight back to his work, put the $200 he'd stolen earlier that night into the safe, and went home.
他爬上一张桌子，穿过舱口出去，直接开车回公司，把那天早些时候偷来的200美元放回保险箱，然后回家。
What's going through your head as you lay down to sleep that night with $5,500 in your bundled-up sweater?
那天晚上你怀揣着那包在毛衣里的5500美元躺下睡觉时，脑子里在想什么？
I was really excited. I mean, I'd figured out a way of doing this. Also thinking, that's the only time that I'm going to do this because now I'll go back to the casino, and I'll win all kinds of money. And I'll just be able to probably not even gamble again. It kind of felt, I guess, at that moment like all of my problems had been solved.
我真的很兴奋。我是说，我终于想出了办法。同时也在想，这将是我最后一次做这种事，因为现在我会回赌场，赢回各种各样的钱。我可能甚至不需要再赌博了。我觉得那一刻，我所有的烦恼似乎都解决了。
This plan, of course, is crazy. When he took the money to the casino, it did not turn into permanent financial stability. He lost it, all of it. But now, he had a way to get it back.
这个计划当然很疯狂。当他把钱带到赌场时，它并没有变成永久的经济稳定。他输光了，全部输光了。但现在，他有了赢回来的办法。
Now this door had been opened, and I knew that I could do this thing to get money.
现在这扇门已经打开了，我知道我可以靠这个弄到钱。
And with this thought, everything changed. The transformation from being one of us to being Spider-Man was as simple as he stumbled onto something that worked. And once he found it, he didn't let it go. He started looking at the city with different eyes.
有了这个想法，一切都变了。从一个普通人变成“蜘蛛侠”，过程就像他偶然发现了一种奏效的方法一样简单。一旦找到它，他就没有放手。他开始用不同的眼光审视这座城市。
I was now being more observant as I was driving around the city. I would just take a look at the one-story shops.
现在我在城里开车时变得更细心了。我会留心那些单层的小店。
Places he could easily climb on top of.
那些他可以轻易爬上去的地方。
Like, in the next five or so blocks, I did a bunch of burglaries.
比如，在接下来的五个街区左右，我做了好几起盗窃案。
We're in the Sunset District. And I knew how many places he'd robbed, but seeing him point to one after another after another kind of blew my mind, made the scale of it seem so much bigger-- a flower shop, a burger joint, a comic book store, a kickboxing gym he climbed into through the skylight.
我们在日落区。我知道他抢了多少地方，但看他指着一个又一个店铺，还是让我大开眼界，案件的规模看起来比我想象中要大得多——一家花店、一家汉堡店、一家漫画书店，还有一个健身房，他是从天窗爬进去的。
Yeah, I just imagined all of the students being very angry and coming and kicking my butt with Thai kickboxing.
是的，我当时想象着所有的学生都非常愤怒，过来用泰拳踢我的屁股。
Further down the block, he points to a series of buildings.
在街区更远处，他指着一排建筑。
One of these places, I had to jump across an alleyway from one building to the other.
其中一个地方，我得从一栋建筑跳过巷子到另一栋去。
Almost every news article mentioned that one. They say he leapt 10 feet between the two buildings. And on the side of one of those buildings--
几乎每一篇新闻报道都提到了那一次。他们说他在两栋建筑之间跳了10英尺。而在其中一栋建筑的侧面——
I was hanging onto a pipe with one hand, and then trying to climb in through these really thin windows that could probably not support my weight. And I thought I'd probably fall and die.
我一只手挂在管道上，试图从那些非常窄的窗户爬进去，那些窗户可能根本承受不住我的体重。我想我大概会掉下去摔死。
He's pointing at places I've been to in a neighborhood where I used to live, including a cafe we used to go to together. I had no idea he'd stolen something from that place. Somehow, that never came up. At the Noriega Produce Market just a few blocks away--
他指的地方我都去过，那是我以前住过的一个街区，包括一家我们以前常去的咖啡馆。我根本不知道他在那儿偷过东西。不知怎么的，那件事从未被提过。在距离这里几个街区的Noriega农贸市场——
I actually took a break in the middle of this burglary to eat an ice cream bar. I guess I had gotten so comfortable at this point where I'm like, union break, right in the middle of this thing. But they wrote it in, actually. Yeah, they wrote it into the police report that I had taken an ice cream bar.
其实我在那次入室盗窃中途还休息了一下，吃了根冰激凌棒。我想我当时已经变得太自在了，心想，工会休息时间，就在这事中间休息下。但警察竟然把它写进去了，真的写进了那份警方报告，说我偷了一根冰激凌棒。
Peter's police report says that, quote, "The manner in which the crimes were carried out indicates planning and sophistication." But if you ask Peter, his primary method was winging it. He wore whatever he had on, didn't case the interiors of the store in advance-- just chose a place and figured out how to break in. He assembled a backpack of misfit tools he'd picked up at random-- garden hose, a carjack, a meat cleaver he used to cut through walls.
Peter的警方报告写着，“作案手法显示其具有计划性和老练程度”。但如果你问Peter，他的主要方法就是随机应变。他穿着手头有的衣服，从不提前踩点——只是选个地方，然后想办法闯进去。他拼凑了一个装满杂乱工具的背包——园艺软管、汽车千斤顶、用来切开墙壁的剁肉刀。
Was there any part of it that was also exciting? Like, fun? Like, you're good at this.
这中间有没有什么让你感到刺激的部分？比如，有趣？就像你很擅长这个。
It wasn't, honestly. What I remember about that time in my life is fear, constant fear. And I didn't want to have to wake up to do these. Again, every time I did this, it was feeling like, I don't want to do this again. This is the last time. This is it. I'm done. I'm done.
老实说，没有。我记得那一时期的生活，只有恐惧，持续的恐惧。我不想醒来做这些。每一次做的时候，我都觉得，我不想再做这种事了。这是最后一次。就是这次了。我受够了，我结束了。
He built himself a double life-- worked at the health club during the day, church on Sundays with us, friends on weekends, and an alarm set for 1:00 or 2:00 AM almost every night, when he'd become Spider-Man. If he found money, he'd come home, shower, and go straight to the casino, immediately. If he didn't, he'd go back to bed and sleep all day. As his friend, it was hard to hear that he'd trapped himself in this terrible life. He says he didn't see it.
他给自己打造了双重生活——白天在健身房工作，周日和我们一起去教会，周末和朋友相处，每天凌晨一点或两点设定闹钟，那时他就是蜘蛛侠。如果找到钱，他会回家，洗澡，然后立刻去赌场。如果没找到，他会回去睡觉，睡上一整天。作为朋友，听到他把自己困在这种可怕的生活里，很难受。他说他自己没看出来。
I don't recall taking a step back and just asking myself, what the heck are you doing?
我不记得自己曾退后一步问自己，你到底在搞什么鬼？
How's that possible? Like, how is it possible that at no point were you like, what am I doing?
怎么可能？你怎么可能从来没有想过，我在做什么？
That's a good question. I'm not really sure. What I know is I didn't want to look at it, honestly. I think that was such a frightening thought, to even look into that chasm because there wasn't another option. It was just keep doing this, and do as many of these as you have to get some money so that you can go back to the casino. And this time, maybe you can win enough money so that you can stop doing this.
这是个好问题。我不太确定。我知道的是，老实说，我不想面对它。我觉得去窥探那个深渊甚至是个非常可怕的想法，因为没有别的选择了。只能继续这样做，做尽可能多的案子弄钱，然后去赌场。也许这次，你可以赢到足够的钱，不用再做这种事了。
But there were so many other options, actually.
但其实还有很多其他的选择。
No, it's true. I think I wanted the easiest way possible. I mean, I certainly wanted to take the path of least resistance.
不，这是真的。我想我只是想要最简单的办法。我的意思是，我当然想走阻力最小的那条路。
But do you hear what you're saying? Because the path of least resistance does not include climbing through skylights. That's not the path of least resistance.
但你听到自己在说什么了吗？因为阻力最小的路并不包括爬天窗。那不是阻力最小的路。
That's true. It took a lot to get me there. That wasn't something that I just wanted to go do. But once I was there, that became the path of least resistance.
没错。为了达到那个程度花了很多心思。那并不是我真的想去做的事。但一旦到了那儿，这就成了阻力最小的路。
It became like a job, but not a good job. He got injured all the time.
这变得像一份工作，但不是一份好工作。他总是受伤。
That's Hotei.
那是Hotei。
Oh, this is the old Japanese restaurant.
哦，这是那家旧的日本餐厅。
Yeah. That's the Japanese restaurant right there.
是的。那家日本餐厅就在那儿。
One night, he got into this restaurant with another ad-libbed tool. He cut the cord off a vacuum cleaner he found, tied it to the roof, and used it to climb down through the skylight. He landed on the floor, looked out the window, and saw a police car.
一天晚上，他用另一个临时凑来的工具进了这家餐厅。他剪断了发现的一个真空吸尘器的线，把它系在屋顶上，用来顺着天窗爬下去。他落在地板上，向窗外看，看到一辆警车。
So there are two really large windows in the front of the restaurant.
餐厅正前方有两扇非常大的窗户。
Those are huge windows. This isn't just like, oh, if you peeked out the window-- and the restaurant isn't big, either. So you're screwed.
那是巨大的窗户。这不只是说，哦，如果你偷看窗外——而且餐厅也不大。所以你死定了。
He crawls to the register, gets the cash. Worried he's tripped a silent alarm, he tries climbing back up, but loses his grip and falls 10 feet, breaking a table and some chairs. His only option now is the front door.
他爬向收银机，拿到了现金。担心触发了静音警报，他试图爬回去，但没抓稳，从10英尺高处掉下来，撞坏了一张桌子和几把椅子。他唯一的选择现在是前门。
And so I walk over to the front door. I unlock it and open it up. I take a step out the door. And to my left, there is a police officer. Immediately, I just reach into the pocket of my jeans, pull out my keys, and act like I'm locking the door. And I say, hey, good evening, officer. And then I walk down the street.
于是我走到前门。我打开锁，推开门。我向外迈了一步。而在我的左侧，有一名警察。我立刻伸手进牛仔裤口袋，掏出钥匙，装作在锁门。我说，嘿，晚上好，警官。然后我就沿着街道走开了。
As he told me these stories, I could see why Peter would be good at this-- the guy who thinks quickly on his feet, cool under pressure, intuitive. That night, he went to his best friend Juliann's house, the one who'd notice the dirt under his fingernails.
当他跟我讲这些故事时，我明白了为什么Peter会擅长这个——这家伙反应敏捷，压力下冷静，很有直觉。那天晚上，他去了他最好的朋友Juliann家，就是那个发现他指甲缝里有泥的人。
I showed up at her house limping and hunched over and just told her I just need to sleep on your couch. And so she knew there was something going on. She just didn't know what it was. And I wasn't about to tell anyone what I was doing.
我一瘸一拐、弯着腰出现在她家，告诉她我只需要睡在你的沙发上。她知道发生了什么事，只是不知道具体是什么。而我当时绝不会告诉任何人我在做什么。
Did you want to?
你想告诉别人吗？
I didn't. I didn't want anyone to know.
我不想。我不想让任何人知道。
He didn't want anyone to know for all the obvious reasons. He was ashamed. But also, he told me he was used to pretending he was in control, to pretending he was like everyone else. Peter was adopted from Korea into a tiny town in Iowa, mostly white, raised by white parents.
出于所有显而易见的原因，他不想让任何人知道。他感到羞愧。而且，他告诉我，他习惯于假装自己掌控一切，假装自己和大家一样。Peter是被从韩国领养到爱荷华州一个小镇上的，那里大多是白人，由白人父母抚养长大。
Honestly, I'd forget that I was Korean until someone would point it out and just kind of snap me back into reality sometimes.
老实说，我常忘了自己是韩国人，直到有人指出来，有时会突然把我拉回现实。
It left him always feeling like an outsider. He put on the Italian shoes, kept his feelings to himself, and hoped no one would notice he was different. And this is the thing that struck me, talking to him about all this. At church, we were all so impressed by how composed Peter was, how well put together, without realizing it was because he was trying so hard to be composed and well put together.
这让他总觉得自己是个局外人。他穿上意大利皮鞋，把感受藏在心底，希望没人注意到他的不同。这正是我和他交谈时触动我的地方。在教会里，我们都对Peter的沉稳和得体印象深刻，却没意识到那是他极力维持的结果。
Peter was a really great thief in some ways, and a really dumb one in others. He never stopped to think, five dozen burglaries in a row in the same neighborhood during the same hours every day-- wouldn't the cops catch on? They did, and caught him. He confessed everything immediately. He served some time, came out.
Peter在某些方面是个非常伟大的窃贼，但在另一些方面却非常蠢。他从未想过，在同一个街区、每天同一时间连续五打盗窃案——警察难道不会察觉吗？他们察觉到了，也抓住了他。他立刻坦白了一切。他服了刑，出来了。
And now, of course, we all knew he was Spider-Man, and we rallied around him and rooted for him as he built this new life and went to meetings for his gambling addiction. He was more involved in church than ever. But within a year, secretly, he started going back to the casino. He started stealing again. And this time, he really started to unravel.
当然，现在我们都知道他是“蜘蛛侠”了，我们支持他、鼓励他开启新生活，并去参加戒赌互助会。他比以往任何时候都更投入教会。但在一年内，他秘密地开始重返赌场，再次开始偷窃。而这一次，他真正开始崩溃了。
Any kind of stealing is pretty tawdry. But because Peter never saw his victims face-to-face, the crime felt a little abstract, like robbing a business and not a person. But one afternoon, he finally committed a crime where he couldn't ignore how ugly it was.
任何形式的盗窃都很卑劣。但因为Peter从未与受害者面对面，犯罪感觉有些抽象，就像抢劫一家企业而不是一个人。但一天下午，他终于犯下了一起无法忽视其丑陋程度的罪行。
After a failed burglary the night before, he drove around looking for something to swipe in broad daylight. He hoped to find a stray purse or wallet, but he couldn't. So when he spotted a young woman walking down the sidewalk with a purse, he made a decision.
在前一天晚上盗窃失败后，他开车四处寻找在光天化日之下能顺手牵羊的东西。他希望能找到一个无主的钱包，但没找到。所以当他看到一个年轻女性走在人行道上拿着钱包时，他做出了一个决定。
And so I started walking up behind her. And the sun was shining towards us. So she couldn't see my shadow as I came up behind her. And I was just walking quickly to try and catch up with her, the whole time just kind of having this inward battle, where I was getting close, and then I slowed down a little bit, and then speeding up. And so finally, I just walked up right behind her. And it's almost as though the second before I touched her purse, it's almost as though I was not in my body when this happened. And I observed this from another angle.
于是我开始跟在她身后。阳光正对着我们，所以我靠近她时，她看不见我的影子。我只是快步走过去试图追上她，整个过程中内心都在挣扎，离得近了，又慢下来，接着又加速。最后，我直接走到了她身后。在那一刻，就像我触碰到她钱包的前一秒，我仿佛灵魂出窍了。我从另一个角度观察到了这一幕。
He grabbed the purse, and to his horror, she wouldn't let go. So he spun her around, and she fell to the ground, and he ran off with her purse.
他抓住了钱包，令他惊恐的是，她不肯松手。于是他转过她，她摔倒在地，他带着她的钱包跑了。
This is really awful. The fact that I victimized another human being, it's still such a source of shame.
这真的太糟糕了。我伤害了另一个人类的事实，至今仍让我感到羞愧。
The next day, he tried to steal another purse from a table at Canvas Cafe, the restaurant that he and I used to go to together sometimes. He was arrested and thrown into jail a second time.
第二天，他又试图在Canvas咖啡馆偷另一个钱包，那家餐厅我和他以前偶尔会去。他被捕了，第二次被关进监狱。
While Peter was behind bars, the guards had heard all about his escapades. They were a little enamored of him. So they took him to an empty corner of the jail one day and dropped a rope down from the ceiling. They wanted to see Spider-Man climb. He was in, he says, the best shape of his life, was doing hundreds of pull-ups and sit-ups every day.
当Peter被关在牢里时，警卫们听说了他的所有事迹，有点迷上他了。所以有一天他们把他带到监狱的一个空角落，从天花板放下绳子。他们想看看蜘蛛侠怎么爬。他说，当时他处于人生中身体状态最好的时候，每天做数百个引体向上和仰卧起坐。
But I could not climb up this rope. And it shocked me, actually. It shocked me based on how strong I was at that point, that I couldn't do something that simple when I had climbed much, much more than that.
但我没能爬上那根绳子。事实上，这让我感到震惊。考虑到我当时有多强壮，我还做不到这么简单的事，而我以前攀爬过比这复杂得多的东西，这让我很震惊。
When I asked him what he thought the difference was, he said desperation. Sheer desperation. That's how he was able to climb up and down ropes and into buildings. That's how Peter became Spider-Man.
当我问他认为区别是什么时，他说那是绝望。纯粹的绝望。这就是他如何爬上爬下绳子并进入建筑物的。这就是Peter成为“蜘蛛侠”的方式。
Karen Duffin is one of the producers of our program. Her friend Peter, by the way, got heavy-duty treatment for his addiction. He hasn't gambled since 2004. Coming up, discovering you can out-Eddie-Murphy Eddie Murphy. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
Karen Duffin是我们节目的制片人之一。顺便说一句，她的朋友Peter因他的成瘾问题接受了重度治疗。他自2004年以来就没再赌过博。接下来，发现你可以比艾迪·墨菲更像艾迪·墨菲。节目继续，稍后为您播出。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, "My Undesirable Talent," stories of people who find they have a special skill that has some upsides, but in the end, vexingly, more bad than good. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, "Uganda Be Kidding Me."
这是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。每周我们都会选择一个主题，为你带来关于该主题的不同故事。今天的节目，“我那令人尴尬的天赋”，讲述的是那些发现自己有一种特殊技能的人，这种技能虽然有些优点，但最终却令人烦恼地弊大于利。我们已经进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“别开玩笑了”。
So in this act, as in the first act, we have another guy who tried something once, kind of almost by accident sort of stumbled onto his special skill, and then ran with it for a while until the problems with it became clear. Neil Drumming explains.
在这一幕中，和第一幕一样，还有另一个家伙，他尝试了某件事一次，简直像是偶然发现了自己的特殊技能，然后一直以此为生，直到其中的问题变得明显。Neil Drumming来为你解释。
This story begins when Zora Bikangaga is about to start at a new college.
这个故事始于Zora Bikangaga即将入读一所新大学之时。
My roommate emailed me first because he was really eager to get to know me. And the first question he asked was, your name is awesome, man. Zora Bikangaga. Where does it come from?
我的室友先给我发了电子邮件，因为他非常想了解我。他问的第一个问题是，你的名字太酷了，伙计。Zora Bikangaga。这是哪来的？
Uganda. Zora's parents are Ugandan. Zora was born in Fresno. It was the summer before he transferred into Westmont College, a small Christian liberal arts school in Santa Barbara. Zora was sitting around with his high school buddies talking about this enthusiastic email he had received. The guy was apparently very excited to meet someone like Zora. Zora's friends, who'd known him for years, found this hilarious.
来自乌干达。Zora的父母是乌干达人。Zora出生在弗雷斯诺。那是他转学到圣巴巴拉的一所小型基督教文理学院Westmont学院之前的那个夏天。Zora和他的高中死党们坐在一起聊着他收到的那封热情的邮件。那个家伙显然对见到像Zora这样的人非常兴奋。Zora的朋友们认识他多年，觉得这太搞笑了。
They were like, dude, he probably thinks you're an international student or something. You know? Zora Bikangaga. Who has a name like that? You should totally act like you're from Africa. And so he called me. I answered the phone. (AFRICAN ACCENT) Hello? Reed! Reed Stoker? You are my roommate, huh?
他们说，伙计，他可能以为你是国际学生什么的。你知道吗？Zora Bikangaga。谁会有这样的名字？你应该完全装作来自非洲的样子。于是他给我打了电话。我接了电话。（非洲口音）喂？Reed！Reed Stoker？你是我的室友，对吗？
The accent was sort of a hybrid of Zora's dad and Eddie Murphy in Coming to America, Zora's favorite movie. Up until then, Zora had only used it to toy with waiters and crack his friends up. It was a joke. Quick comparison-- here's Eddie Murphy.
那种口音某种程度上是Zora父亲的声音和Zora最喜欢的电影《来到美国》中艾迪·墨菲角色的混合体。在那之前，Zora只用过它来捉弄服务员和逗乐朋友。这只是个玩笑。快速对比一下——这是艾迪·墨菲。
Hello. I am Akeem. I'm a student.
你好，我是Akeem，我是个学生。
And now here's Zora.
现在是Zora。
(AFRICAN ACCENT) Hello? Reed!
（非洲口音）喂？Reed！
Anyway, back to our story.
总之，回到我们的故事。
Wow, this is crazy. This dude is straight out of Africa.
哇，这太疯狂了。这家伙完全就是从非洲出来的。
This is Zora's roommate. His name is Reed. Even now, he's pretty stoked when he remembers the call.
这是Zora的室友。他叫Reed。即使是现在，当他想起那个电话时，依然感到非常兴奋。
I was like, check this guy's accent. He's like some prince of some lake region. So I was excited that I got a very unique roommate to go alongside of my general excitement for going away to college.
我当时心想，听听这家伙的口音。他就像某个湖区的王子。所以我很兴奋，除了对上大学的一般性兴奋外，我还得到了一个非常独特的室友。
Zora could have shown up on the first day of school speaking in his regular voice. But his friends back home wanted to see if he could fool Reed face-to-face. For that, he'd need more than an accent.
Zora本可以在开学第一天就用正常的口音说话。但他在家乡的朋友们想看看他能否当面骗过Reed。为此，他需要的不仅仅是口音。
I had this shirt on that I got in Uganda. It was a very traditional, vibrant print shirt that I got in Kampala. And I was like, all right. I'm gonna wear this shirt and these sandals that I got in Africa to look the part.
我穿着一件我在乌干达买的衬衫。那是一件我在坎帕拉买的、非常有传统色彩且鲜艳的印花衬衫。我心想，好吧，我要穿上这件衬衫和我在非洲买的凉鞋，装得像模像样。
He figured he'd mess with the guy for a few minutes at the most. But when Zora got to the dorm, Reed wasn't alone.
他原本想，最多也就捉弄那家伙几分钟。但当Zora到达宿舍时，Reed身边并不只有他一个人。
He was there with his dad and his little sister, this white family from Orange County. And immediately, they were so warm to me and so friendly. And I remember his little sister was 13 or 14 at the time. And she was so interested in Uganda. And she was so endearing and fascinated by my background. I had never had someone react to me in that way.
他和他的父亲以及小妹妹在一起，这是一个来自奥兰治县的白人家庭。他们立刻对我非常热情，非常友好。我记得他小妹妹当时13或14岁，她对乌干达非常感兴趣。她被我的背景迷住了，表现得极其可爱。我以前从未遇到过有人对我做出那种反应。
Zora pulled from his parents' experiences and his limited knowledge of Africa to dazzle Reed's family with descriptions of tribes and exotic animals. Again, it could have stopped there. But it was the first day of school, and there were a lot of people who wanted to meet him.
Zora利用父母的经历和他对非洲有限的了解，向Reed的家人描述部落和珍奇异兽，让他们大开眼界。同样，这本来可以到此为止。但那是开学第一天，很多人都想见他。
Everyone's around you. My RA came in. The neighbors came in. We were meeting so many people to where I didn't have time to drop the character. It snowballed.
周围全是人。我的宿舍助理来了，邻居也来了。我们要见的太多了，我根本没时间卸下伪装。事情就像滚雪球一样失控了。
Zora stayed in character. He met a bunch of people, all of whom seemed delighted to get to know him. He was enjoying the warm reception so much that he felt a pang of regret when he was introduced to two Kenyan students, actual African students. He knew the game was over.
Zora坚持了这个角色。他见了一大群人，大家都对他表现出的兴趣感到高兴。他非常享受这种热烈的欢迎，以至于当他被介绍给两名肯尼亚学生——真正的非洲学生时，他感到了一丝遗憾。他知道游戏结束了。
And I was like, all right. This is it. I was introduced to them. And they're like, oh, man, you're from Uganda. I went to Kampala. And we started to talk about Nairobi. And I know about Nairobi because my mom lived there as a teenager. She actually went to school there. And I spoke a little Swahili. And they knew a little bit of Luganda, which isn't even my parents' language, but it's the main language in Uganda.
我心想，好吧，就是这样了。我被介绍给他们。他们说，噢，伙计，你是来自乌干达。我去过坎帕拉。于是我们开始谈论内罗毕。我知道内罗毕的情况，因为我妈十几岁时就在那儿住过。她甚至在那儿读过书。我会说一点斯瓦希里语。他们知道一点卢干达语，那甚至不是我父母的语言，但那是乌干达的主要语言。
And I guess I knew enough about Uganda to the point where it's like, yeah. They were like, all right. Yeah, he's from-- OK. He's from Uganda. And I look like I'm from Uganda. That's when it got real to me. And I was like, these two guys think that I'm from Uganda, these two Kenyans. This is a real thing. I can do this for a long time. Actually, I could probably get away with this forever.
我想我对乌干达了解得足够多，以至于他们说，好的，是的，他来自——好的，他来自乌干达。而且我看起来就像来自乌干达。那一刻，我觉得这一切变成真的了。我心想，这两个家伙认为我来自乌干达，这两个肯尼亚人。这竟然成真的了。我可以玩很久。其实我可能可以永远瞒下去。
Zora was thrilled and also a bit terrified by his new superpower. He was part Storm, part Mystique, but a dude. He needed to talk to the only people who knew his secret identity.
Zora对自己这种新获得的超能力既兴奋又有点恐惧。他有点像“暴风女”，又有点像“魔形女”，但他是个男的。他需要和那些唯一知道他真实身份的人谈谈。
The first thing I did was I called my best friends back home. And I was like, they bought it. And they're like, oh, that's hilarious! And I was like, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. You don't understand. Everyone thinks that I'm this guy. I was kind of freaking out on the phone with them. And they were like, no this is-- they thought it was so funny.
我做的第一件事就是打给家乡的好友们。我说，他们信了。他们说，噢，那太搞笑了！我说，不，不，不，不。你们不明白。每个人都以为我是那个家伙。我在电话里有点崩溃了。他们觉得这太好玩了。
And I was like, no, you don't understand. This is a small school. And the orientation leaders think that I'm this guy. I met like a couple professors. You don't understand. And they're like, you got to keep going with this. You can be a completely different person. You can have so much fun with this. Do you understand what you've done? You've got to see how long you can do it.
我说，不，你们不懂。这是一所小学校。Orientation的负责人都认为我是那个家伙。我见了好几个教授。你们不懂。他们说，你一定要坚持下去。你可以成为一个完全不同的人。你可以从中获得很多乐趣。你知道你做了什么吗？你得看看你能撑多久。
This is not good advice. These are your good friends?
这可不是好建议。这些是你的好朋友吗？
Yeah. Yeah, I mean these were guys that I grew up with, that I was close with. But again, they were 18. I mean, I saw the fun in it. Did I want to have the same experience as I did in high school? No, of course not. High school was rough. It was rough for me.
是啊。我是说，这些是我一起长大、关系很近的人。但再一次，他们才18岁。我的意思是，我看到了其中的乐趣。我想经历高中时那样的生活吗？不，当然不想。高中对我来说很艰难。太艰难了。
Zora spent most of his childhood in a small, very white town in wine country, northern California, called Healdsburg. His father was a cardiovascular surgeon. And Healdsburg was exactly the kind of place where you'd expect the son of a successful doctor to blend in and thrive. Zora spoke like the other kids in the neighborhood. He played like the other kids in the neighborhood. He just didn't look like the other kids in the neighborhood.
Zora童年大部分时间是在北加州葡萄酒之乡一个小型、非常白人化的城镇——希尔兹堡度过的。他父亲是心血管外科医生。希尔兹堡正是那种你期望成功人士的儿子能够融入并茁壮成长的地方。Zora说话和街坊里的其他孩子一样。他玩耍的方式也和邻居孩子一样。他只是看起来不像邻居里的其他孩子。
And then there was one other black kid in the town that was adopted, Ben Jackson. And he had one arm. We always used to joke that I was the black kid with two arms, and he was the black kid with one arm, like we didn't have a name. You know? It was like, what up, one arm? What up, two arms? That kind of thing. I felt bad for him.
还有一个被领养的黑人孩子，Ben Jackson。他少了一只胳膊。我们过去常开玩笑说，我是那个有两只胳膊的黑人小孩，他是那个只有一只胳膊的黑人小孩，好像我们没有名字一样。你懂吗？那种感觉就像，嘿，单臂！嘿，双臂！那种调调。我为他感到难过。
As one of the few black kids around, Zora stomached his share of snubs. He was called colorful names like porch monkey, coon, and spear chucker. Oh, and [BLEEP]. Once, a playmate refused to let him use his bathroom for fear his skin color would rub off in the toilet.
作为周围极少数的黑人孩子之一，Zora忍受了应有的轻视。他被冠以“ porch monkey”（对黑人的种族歧视称呼）、“ coon ”和“ spear chucker ”这些充满色彩的名字。哦，还有“ [BLEEP] ”。有一次，一个玩伴因为害怕他的肤色会蹭到马桶上，拒绝让他使用自家的洗手间。
These slights baffled Zora because for the most part, he didn't see himself as being different from his friends. And because he never talked to his parents about this stuff, it sometimes weirdly fell to his white friends to explain to him exactly what the hell was going on. Like that time in middle school when he was hanging out with his buddies at a neighborhood store, and the clerk made Zora-- only Zora-- empty his pockets to see if he was stealing.
这些轻视让Zora感到困惑，因为在很大程度上，他不认为自己和朋友们有什么不同。由于他从不和父母谈论这些，有时奇怪的是，反而得由他的白人朋友来向他解释到底发生了什么。比如中学时，他和伙伴们在一家街边店闲逛，店员让Zora——只有Zora——清空口袋查看他是否在偷窃。
My best friend at the time was like, I can't believe he did that because you're black. And it dawned on me-- that was because I was black. I really didn't see myself as different than everyone else in that way. And it was just moments like that that was like, you're black. You're black. You're black.
当时我最好的朋友说，我真不敢相信他竟然那么做，只因为你是黑人。我突然意识到——那是因为我是黑人。我真的没觉得自己在那种意义上和别人有什么不同。就是在那一刻，我意识到：你是黑人。你是黑人。你是黑人。
In high school, Zora hit it off with a white girl, but the romance was over before it started.
在高中时，Zora和一个白人女孩很合得来，但这段恋情还没开始就结束了。
She told her dad that she liked me or whatever. And her dad said, if you go out with him, don't ever bother coming back home. And I was like, wait, she would be disowned for talking to me? I'm just like my friend Brian. If she went out with my friend Brian, it would have been fine.
她告诉她爸爸她喜欢我什么的。她爸说，如果你和他出去，就别指望再回家了。我当时心想，等一下，她因为跟我说话就要被赶出家门？我就像我朋友Brian一样。如果她和Brian出去，那就没问题。
Zora went from being frustrated by all the indignities and exclusion to being guarded and distrustful of most people.
Zora从对所有屈辱和排挤感到沮丧，转变为对大多数人保持警惕和怀疑。
Personality-wise, I'm naturally very extroverted. But I had to put this barrier around me, I think. I mean, not that I was losing my temper all the time or anything like that. But I was more closed off, for sure.
性格上，我天生非常外向。但我必须在自己周围设下这道防线，我想。并不是说我总是在发脾气或者别的什么。但我确实更加封闭了。
Zora wasn't happy with this unhappy person he'd become. So when he got to Westmont and the opportunity arose to become yet another new person, someone who drew others to him rather than repulsing them, Zora seized it.
Zora对成为这种不快乐的自己并不满意。所以当他到了Westmont，并且有机会成为另一个新人——一个吸引别人而不是排斥别人的人时，Zora抓住了机会。
I could be extroverted. I could be open and friendly and talk to a lot of different kinds of people and be gregarious and funny, make people laugh. And people loved this guy. And as it went along, I felt conflicted about it. But I was also kind of like, this guy is me. There's a part of me in this guy in that whatever people love about this guy, they love me.
我可以表现得外向。我可以开放、友好，与各种各样的人交谈，变得好交际、风趣，让人发笑。人们喜欢这个家伙。随着时间的推移，我感到很矛盾。但我也心想，这个家伙就是我。这个家伙身上有一部分是我，无论人们爱这个家伙的什么，他们爱的是我。
The way that I say my name in American English would be Zora Beacon-gaga or Zora Be-con-gaga. But the way that I would say my full name would be (AFRICAN ACCENT) Zora Bikangaga or Muzora Bikangaga, which is the full name. Muzora Bikangaga.
我用美式英语念我的名字应该是Zora Beacon-gaga，但念我的全名应该是（非洲口音）Zora Bikangaga或Muzora Bikangaga，这是全名。Muzora Bikangaga。
I remember seeing him walk into campus. And I was like, yes! Because we always feel that way. Yes, another black person! A black guy! That's awesome!
我记得看到他走进校园。我心想，耶！因为我们总是有这种感觉。耶，又一个黑人！一个黑人小伙！太棒了！
This is Angie. She says everyone at Westmont College seemed to love Zora.
这是Angie。她说Westmont学院的每个人似乎都喜欢Zora。
He had this regalness about him, in bulk. Everyone was quiet and listened. 'Cause with that accent comes a lot of pauses and a lot of thoughtfulness. So it was very, like, what is he gonna say?
他身上有一种贵族气派，整个人都是。大家都很安静，听他说话。因为那种口音伴随着大量的停顿和思考。所以大家感觉就像，他要说什么？
Even as a fellow black student, Angie was not immune to thinking of Zora as someone unusual and exciting.
即使作为黑人学生，Angie也不能免俗，依然把Zora看作一个与众不同且令人兴奋的人。
Oh, he's from another country. That resonated more with me because it was more interesting to me that he just wasn't an American black guy. I can learn about his culture, where he's from. That'd be amazing.
噢，他来自另一个国家。这对我来说更感共鸣，因为他不是那种美式黑人小伙子，这对我来说更有意思。我可以了解他的文化，了解他来自哪里。那太棒了。
So Angie and Zora got very close over the course of the semester. She says they were full fledged BFF's. When they weren't in class, they spent days exploring Santa Barbara together. They watched movies. They played basketball. And they listened to a ton of hip-hop. On Angie's 18th birthday, Zora surprised her with a copy of Common's Like Water for Chocolate.
所以Angie和Zora在那个学期走得很近。她说他们是彻头彻尾的死党。不上课的时候，他们整天一起探索圣巴巴拉。他们看电影，打篮球，听大量的嘻哈音乐。在Angie 18岁生日那天，Zora给了她一张Common的《Like Water for Chocolate》唱片作为惊喜。
I was so excited. It made my whole birthday that he got me this CD. And we would just talk about the lyrics and stuff. And I was like, it's so cool. Because I'd be like, in Africa, you guys have this? You know about Common? How did you see him? On TV? I was so fascinated.
我太兴奋了。他送我这张CD让我的整个生日都完美了。我们常谈论歌词什么的。我心想，这太酷了。因为我会问，在非洲，你们有这个吗？你知道Common？你是怎么看到他的？在电视上？我太着迷了。
Yeah, she was fascinated with my background. And so I felt so guilty about that. But also, I was really into her, as well. She was beautiful. She was outspoken. And she was this amazing girl. And we got really close.
是的，她对我的背景着迷。所以我对此感到非常内疚。但同时，我也很喜欢她。她美丽、直率，是一个了不起的女孩。我们走得很近。
BFF close, but not more.
死党般的亲近，但仅此而已。
I want a woman that's going to arouse my intellect as well as my loins.
我想要一个既能激发我智力又能撩拨我欲望的女人。
Sorry. That was Eddie Murphy again. I couldn't help myself. Zora says he didn't get physically intimate with anyone the entire time he was in character. He figured if he ever got found out, that would just make his shenanigan seem infinitely more sinister. Zora kept the facade up for months, almost the whole semester, and no one had a clue. They may have even been predisposed not to have a clue. Here's Zora's roommate, Reed, again.
抱歉。那又是艾迪·墨菲。我没忍住。Zora说他在伪装期间没有和任何人发生过身体上的亲密行为。他想如果哪天穿帮了，那会让他的恶作剧看起来无限邪恶。Zora维持了这个假面数月，几乎整个学期，没人察觉。他们甚至可能预先就没打算察觉。这是Zora的室友Reed。
It wasn't just the accent. It's the fact that he's 6' 7". He was a really dark black guy in a white, rich-kid college. And so I think people kind of wanted to know him and were intrigued by him. And I think in a way, at a Christian school like that, I think people were motivated to proactively show how accepting they were to different kinds of people.
不仅仅是因为口音。这是因为他有6英尺7英寸高。他是一个真正黑肤色的黑人，在那种白人、富家子弟扎堆的大学里。所以我认为人们很想了解他，对他很感兴趣。而且我认为在那种基督教学校里，人们有动力主动表现出他们对不同类型的人是多么包容。
And Zora encouraged them to believe he was different, the right kind of different.
Zora鼓励他们相信他是与众不同的，是一种正确类型的不同。
So that was part of your persona, was international student. There was no Healdsburg. There was no American home. You came from Uganda to go to school.
所以国际学生就是你形象的一部分。没有希尔兹堡，没有美国老家。你是从乌干达来读书的。
Well, so here's what happened-- yes, but I had this old '73 Oldsmobile Delta 88 convertible. And it was this old boat. And we would drive down to the beach. So I had a bunch of people in the back seat. The car was packed. And there was a yearbook that I forgot under my seat.
嗯，发生的事情是这样的——是的，但我有这辆73年的奥兹莫比尔Delta 88敞篷车。那是一艘老船。我们会开车去海滩。后座挤满了人。车里塞满了，我忘了那本纪念册放在座位底下。
And there was a girl back there that saw the yearbook. And she started flipping through it. And I was like, oh, man. I'm done. I'm done. They found out that I'm from Healdsburg. And she was like, Zora, why are you in this yearbook? And I was like, (AFRICAN ACCENT) oh, no. I was a foreign exchange student for a year. I was with a family.
有个女孩在后座看到了那本纪念册。她开始翻看起来。我心想，噢，完了。我完了。他们发现我来自希尔兹堡。她说，Zora，为什么你会在这本纪念册里？我当时（非洲口音）说，哦，不。我做了一年的外国交换生。我是和一家人住在一起的。
And so I said I'd been in the States for a year. And that's why I had the car. And they're like, oh, OK. And it just went on.
于是我说我在美国待了一年。这就是我为什么有这辆车。他们说，噢，好吧。事情就这么过去了。
Were you in college at one point-- this is the first semester-- thinking, God, this is so much better than it used to be? Or did you think, this is worse in a different way?
你在读大学的时候——那是在第一学期——有没有想过，天哪，这比以前好多了？还是你觉得，这是另一种意义上的糟糕？
No, it was better.
不，更好。
It felt better.
感觉更好。
100% better. Yeah. I was having a blast.
好上一百倍。是的。我玩得很开心。
Yeah.
是啊。
I was getting to know people. I was hanging out with girls. I like to dance. And so people got a kick out of that, me going in the circle and doing the Roger Rabbit or something like that. They're like, where did you learn that?
我在结交朋友，我在和女孩们出去玩。我喜欢跳舞。所以大家觉得很有趣，看我在圈子里跳Roger Rabbit之类的舞。他们问，你在哪学的？
So everything was just way cooler as this guy, where I was like, if I did that in high school, they'd be like, all right. The black kid can dance. We know that. But it was just so cool for me to go in there and do the running man. They just got a kick out of that.
所以一切作为那个家伙都酷多了，我心想，如果我在高中那样做，他们会说，好吧，那个黑人孩子会跳舞，我们知道。但对我来说，进去跳“running man”感觉太酷了。他们只是觉得很有趣。
OK, because I remember doing the running man surrounded by white folks. And to this day, that is not a good feeling. That's not a pleasant memory that I have. And I'm just wondering, at any moment, did you think, I don't like the fact that I'm performing? Or was it just too much-- like, people were nice, and it didn't bother you?
好的，因为我还记得在白人簇拥下跳“running man”的感觉。直到今天，那也不是什么好感觉。那不是什么愉快的记忆。我只是好奇，有没有任何时刻你觉得自己不喜欢在表演？还是说人们太友好了，让你觉得没关系？
I didn't see it as me purely entertaining them. I felt very, very in control of the situation. So if I felt like going in and dancing, that was because I wanted to. You never want to be that token black guy. Like, all right, well, I'm the good dancer.
我不觉得我纯粹是在娱乐他们。我觉得自己非常、非常有掌控权。所以如果我想进去跳舞，那是因为我想去。你永远不想成为那个“象征性的黑人”。比如，好吧，我是个优秀的舞者。
Yeah.
是啊。
But it was different as an African. It was different. It was shocking to them that I knew how to do those things. I mean, it was funny to me. I was like, (AFRICAN ACCENT) yeah, I've seen House Party. You know, this is one of my favorite movies.
但作为非洲人感觉不同。这真的不同。他们对我知道怎么做这些事感到震惊。对我来说很好笑。我心想，（非洲口音）是的，我看过《House Party》。你知道，这是我最喜欢的电影之一。
As much fun as it was being universally adored, Zora started to get annoyed by how little anyone at his school knew about African culture. He found that he could tell them anything, and they would believe it.
尽管被大家崇拜很有趣，但Zora开始对他学校里的人对非洲文化了解得如此之少感到厌烦。他发现他可以告诉他们任何事，他们都会相信。
With the people that would ask me stupid questions, I'd push it. I would straight up say, (AFRICAN ACCENT) yeah, the rose petal thing in Coming to America, that's based on-- it's a thing. It happens.
对于那些问我愚蠢问题的人，我会变本加厉。我会直截了当地说，（非洲口音）是的，像《来到美国》里那种洒花瓣的事，那是——是真的，确实会发生。
He's talking about that scene in the movie where the scantily-clad servants sprinkle rose petals at the prince's feet wherever he walks.
他说的是电影里那个场景：衣着暴露的仆人在王子的每一步脚下撒花瓣。
And they're like, no. And I'm like, yeah. And they're like, oh. I just would really push it. I remember this girl was asking me about my background. And she was like, do you have any exotic pets at all? Is there something? And I was like, (AFRICAN ACCENT) yeah, like, everyone gets a lion, a cub. And you grow up with it, and it becomes your lion.
他们说，不。我说，是真的。他们说，噢。我会变本加厉。我记得有个女孩问我背景。她说，你有异国宠物吗？有没有什么？我说，（非洲口音）是的，每个人都会领养一只狮子幼崽，你养着它长大，它就成了你的狮子。
And she was like, are you serious? That's so cool. I was like, (AFRICAN ACCENT) yeah. Do you have a dog? You know, that kind of thing where I was like, wait. They believe me? I can push this-- she thought that everyone gets a lion? That's insane. This is an educated adult or someone that is in college.
她说，你是认真的吗？那太酷了。我说，（非洲口音）是的。你有狗吗？你知道那种感觉，我心想，等等。他们信我？我可以玩得这么大——她觉得每个人都有狮子？太疯狂了。这是一个受过教育的成年人，或者是正在读大学的人。
So why did you decide to come out as a regular black person?
那你为什么要决定坦白自己只是个普通黑人？
I know, right? That's such a ridiculous thing to do. Because I didn't want to do it forever. It got old to me after a while. I wanted people to know who I was.
我知道，对吧？那是件非常荒唐的事。因为我不想永远这样。过了一段时间我觉得厌倦了。我想让大家知道我是谁。
So you stopped telling yourself that this was part of who you were. That didn't fly with you forever.
所以你不再告诉自己这是你的一部分。那套说法对你来说不是长久之计。
That can only go so far. And especially when I started to learn the pitfalls of being this guy, of the condescending nature, the undermining, the ignorance of Africa or Africans. That got old to me.
那只能维持一阵子。尤其是当我开始了解到当这个家伙的陷阱时——那种居高临下的态度、轻视、对非洲或非洲人的无知。那让我感到厌烦。
Zora decided to end the prank with a prank. He started with his roommate.
Zora决定用一个恶作剧来结束这个恶作剧。他从他的室友开始。
And so he came in one day. And he was checking our messages. Because back then, the dorm rooms had landlines. So he was checking the voicemail. And I was like, yo, did anybody call for me? Did my homies call for me? I did this sort of exaggerated American accent.
有一天他进来了，在查我们的留言。因为那时候宿舍房间都有固定电话。他在查语音信箱。我说，哟，有人给我打电话吗？我的哥们儿打了吗？我用了那种夸张的美国口音。
He was like, hey, yo, any of my chicks call for me or what? And I was kind of like, what'd you say? And then he goes, (AFRICAN ACCENT) oh, my American accent. It's very good, no? I've been practicing.
他说，嘿，哟，有我的妞给我打过电话吗？我有点像，你说什么？然后他说，（非洲口音）哦，我的美国口音，很不错吧？我一直在练习。
(AFRICAN ACCENT) Was that convincing?
（非洲口音）那听起来很有说服力吗？
Yeah it was really good. Wow. And then he came back and was like--
是啊，非常好。哇。然后他走回来，说——
Well, what if I told you that I grew up in Healdsburg. And--
嗯，如果我告诉你我是在希尔兹堡长大的呢。而且——
No, but seriously, Reed, I'm not from Africa. I'm from Fresno.
不，说真的，Reed，我不是来自非洲。我来自弗雷斯诺。
I was born in Fresno, and I'm not from Uganda. And he just stared at me for-- it seemed like 30 seconds. And he's like, I got to go. And he left for, like, an hour.
我出生在弗雷斯诺，我不是来自乌干达。他盯着我看了——大概有30秒。然后他说，我得走了。他离开了一个小时。
Call it the resilience of youth, but Reed was over it by the time he got back to the dorm room. Zora broke the truth to the rest of his guy friends the same way.
这叫年轻人的韧性，Reed回到宿舍时已经没那么在意了。Zora用同样的方式向其他男性朋友说了实话。
One by one, they came in. And so I sort of flipped back and forth, like, (AFRICAN ACCENT) how was my accent? Was it good? Yeah, but what if I talk like this? I'm totally from Healdsburg. And I revealed myself. And the person would stay to see the other person's reaction.
他们一个接一个进来。我就这样来回切换，比如，（非洲口音）我的口音怎么样？好吗？耶，但是如果我这样说话呢？我完全来自希尔兹堡。我摊牌了。对方会留下来看下一个人的反应。
Eventually, he outed himself in the school newspaper. Half the school thought it was the brilliant final act of a grand performance art piece, thereby giving Zora another role to play.
最终，他在校报上公开了自己。学校的一半人认为这是某种伟大的行为艺术，是光辉的终章，这又给了Zora一个新的角色去扮演。
This is before Borat came out. But they saw me that way, of, like, man, he's a comedic genius. This was a giant parody and social experiment. And maybe I played into that a little bit. I was like, yeah, yeah. I learned a lot from this. And for sure, maybe I leaned into that a little bit.
这在《波拉特》上映之前。但他们那样看我，心想，天哪，他是个喜剧天才。这是一个巨大的讽刺和社会实验。也许我顺水推舟演了一点。我说，是啊是啊，我从中学到了很多。确实，也许我确实顺水推舟了一点点。
The president of the college called Zora into his office to interrogate him. He wanted to know if he was somehow taking advantage of the school financially. Was he receiving some scholarship or financial aid package for foreign students that he didn't deserve? It was like that store in Healdsburg all over again. Zora wasn't stealing. He was guilty only of being black. When it came time to tell Angie the truth, Zora decided to do pretty much exactly what he'd done with his roommate, but a little more tenderly because, you know, he liked her.
校长把Zora叫进办公室讯问他。他想知道他是否在经济上占学校的便宜。他是否领取了某种他不配得到的外国学生奖学金或资助包？这就像在希尔兹堡的那家店一样。Zora没有偷窃。他唯一的罪过就是他是黑人。当轮到向Angie坦白真相时，Zora决定做的和对室友做的几乎一模一样，但稍微温柔一点，因为你知道，他喜欢她。
So you let her in. Like, you opened the door or whatever. She comes over, and you're speaking to her in an African accent. And then you stop?
所以你让她进来了。你打开门什么的。她走过来，你用非洲口音跟她说话。然后你停下来？
Yeah. Yeah, yeah. I just was like, Angie, I'm not from Uganda. And I tried to tell her. I was like, look, you know, we got along as people. You know what I mean? And whatever you liked about me is me. I wanted to be really honest with Angie because she was the one that I felt the most bad about.
是的。是的，我只是说，Angie，我不是来自乌干达。我试图告诉她，我说，你看，我们作为人相处得很好。你知道我的意思吗？无论你喜欢我什么，那都是我。我试图对Angie诚实，因为我觉得最对不起的就是她。
Yeah.
是啊。
And so I tried to be more sincere about it.
所以我试图在这件事上表现得更真诚一些。
Angie doesn't remember it that way.
Angie的记忆却并非如此。
He said something like, oh, I think you're hot or cute or something. It was something really American, stupid American boy, which to me decreased your level of regalness, in my mind. It made him a whole new person just because of-- I can't remember exactly what he said.
他说了一些类似“噢，我觉得你很火辣或很可爱”之类的话。那是非常美式的，愚蠢的美国小男孩的话，在我看来，这降低了你的贵族气。这让他变成了一个完全不同的人——我记不清他具体说了什么。
But whatever he said made him a whole new person to me on top of the fact that your voice is different, on top of the fact that when I'm asking you all these things about where you just came from, none of those have been your experience. They may have been your parents' experiences, but you're making all this stuff. All this is made up. Because it was like, you've been acting like an-- and I told him, you should be a professional. You've been acting this whole time.
但他说的任何话都让他变成了一个全新的、甚至更糟的人。你的声音变了，而且我问你关于你刚从哪儿来的一切，那些经历都不是你的。那可能是你父母的经历，但你全都是编的。因为就像是，你一直在演——我告诉他，你应该去当个专业演员。你一直在演戏。
Zora Bikangaga went from being rejected by a white girl because he was black to being rejected by a black girl because he was just black. And that's not even the end of it.
Zora Bikangaga从因为是黑人而被白人女孩拒绝，变成了因为同样是黑人而被黑人女孩拒绝。而这还不是终点。
And the last thing that she said before she stormed off, she was like, and you sound like a white boy, which was her final dagger that she stuck in my heart.
在她愤然离去前，她说的最后一句话是：而且你听起来像个白人小伙。那是她插在我心头的最后一刀。
Identity can be funny at that age. Maybe you don't like the way people see you. You want to try something new. You experiment. College kids do it all the time. But being black in America is not like being awkward or having the wrong clothes or being bad at sports. When you're black and someone makes up their mind about you the moment they see you, without you ever having a chance to speak up and announce yourself, it can be so diminishing. It can be heartbreaking. Hell, it can be life-threatening.
在这个年龄，身份认同是件有趣的事。也许你不喜欢别人看你的方式。你想尝试新东西，你去实验。大学生们一直都在做。但在美国作为黑人，和笨拙、穿错衣服或运动能力差完全不同。当你身为黑人，有人在你见到他们那一刻就认定了你的样子，甚至没给你开口说话的机会，这真是非常令人压抑。这让人心碎。天哪，这甚至会危及生命。
Zora wasn't thinking about any of that when he went all Prince Akeem on a whole university. He certainly didn't anticipate that being perceived as fresh from Africa would come with its own set of wild assumptions. He was just goofing around. He stumbled into a place where he suddenly felt welcome and accepted, and he went with it. He clung to it, even if it meant he had to perpetuate a lie.
Zora在把整个大学当成Akeem王子去耍的时候，没想过那些。他当然没预料到被认为刚从非洲来会伴随一系列狂野的假设。他只是在闹着玩。他偶然闯入了一个他突然感到受欢迎和被接受的地方，于是他顺势而为。他紧紧抓住它，即使这意味着他必须维持一个谎言。
This new lie felt better than the ones that had been written about him long before he was born because, at least for a while, it felt like it was his to control. It's something any of us might have done, if we had the chops to pull it off.
这个新谎言感觉比他出生前就被定义好的谎言更好，因为至少有一段时间，这感觉是他可以掌控的。这是我们任何人都可能做的事，如果我们有能力做到的话。
Neil Drumming is one of the producers of our program. Zora Bikangaga, by the way, just this year quit his teaching job and is trying out a new career-- acting.
Neil Drumming是我们节目的制片人之一。顺便说一句，Zora Bikangaga今年刚辞去了教职，正在尝试新的职业——表演。
Act three, "Disbarred." So one of the things that we realized here at the radio show when we were talking about this week's theme amongst ourselves-- this theme "My Undesirable Talent"-- we realized that most talents have some undesirable side to them. Case in point, if you're an athlete or a dancer-- and especially if you get to the point where people pay you to do it, you're in the elite, you're that gifted. Of course, that is fantastic. But one deeply undesirable part of having that kind of talent is that you age out of it. And depending on what you're doing, you can age out of it in your 20s or your 30s.
第三幕，“吊销资格”。所以，我们电台在讨论这一周的主题“我那令人尴尬的天赋”时意识到——大多数天赋都有某种不受欢迎的一面。举个例子，如果你是个运动员或舞者——尤其是当你达到别人花钱请你做这个水平的时候，你是精英，你是天才。当然，这很棒。但拥有这种天赋的一个极度不受欢迎的部分是，你会变老。取决于你在做什么，你在20多岁或30多岁时就会被迫退休。
I remember teachers saying, dance this like it's the last time you're gonna dance.
我记得老师说，跳这支舞，就像这是你最后一次跳舞一样。
This is Wendy Whelan, one of the greatest dancers in the world, a principal dancer with the New York City Ballet starting in 1991. She left the New York City Ballet in 2014. And she talked about the experience of walking away from this job that she loved, that she was a master of, in this radio documentary that I heard. And to close out today's show, they gave us permission to play a little excerpt of it here. Here we go.
这就是Wendy Whelan，世界上最伟大的舞者之一，自1991年起担任纽约市芭蕾舞团的首席舞者。她于2014年离开。她在一段我听过的广播纪录片中谈到了放弃这份她所热爱、她所精通的工作的经历。为了结束今天的节目，他们授权我们播放其中的一小段。我们开始吧。
The day I slipped-- I slipped in class. And I knew I had done something dramatic to the back of my hamstring or hip. And I went ahead, and I went to rehearsal. And I thought, OK, I'll just see how this feels. And I started rehearsing. And my partner and I slipped again, again re-pulling the same injury in my body that had just happened two hours previous.
我滑倒的那一天——我在课上滑倒了。我知道我把腿筋或臀部后部弄伤了，动作很夸张。我还是去了排练。我心想，好吧，看看感觉如何。我开始排练。我和搭档又滑倒了，再次拉伤了几个小时前刚受过伤的部位。
And I was just like, oh, my god. Fate is absolutely stepping in right now and giving me a message. And then I had another rehearsal. And I told the powers that be, my ballet mistress and my boss-- I just said, I pulled my hamstring today. And so I'm going to do this, but it's a little bit sore. And I'm kind of being a little careful. And then I pulled myself out of other repertory that I knew I couldn't do.
我当时就想，天哪，命运现在绝对是在介入，给我一个讯息。然后我还有另一场排练。我告诉了权力部门，我的芭蕾舞老师和老板——我只是说，我今天拉伤了腿筋。所以我还要做这个，但有点疼，我会小心点。然后我退出了其他我知道做不了的剧目。
And I was doing the one piece, and the administrative team was like, can you do that bigger and with a little more clarity? And I was just like, uh, actually, no. I can't. And it was really just the first time I had to say no. I've always been able-- yes, I can do that. Yes, I can do that. Yes, I can do that. No, I can't do that anymore.
我在做那一个片段时，管理团队说，你能做得再大方一点，更清晰一点吗？我当时心想，呃，其实，不行。我做不到了。这是我第一次不得不说“不”。我以前总是能做到——是的，我能做。是的，我能做。是的，我能做。不，我再也做不到了。
It's terrifying. Yeah, terrifying. I watched many people retire before me. And I've felt the energy of losing them and them cutting themself away from the company. And there's a lot of feelings that go in that. And I think being the one that's leaving somehow-- I don't know. I imagine it like death a little bit, whereas you look at it, and you're afraid of it. And then you're actually experiencing it, and there's no pain. And it's out of your hands.
这很可怕。是啊，很可怕。我看着许多人在我之前退休。我感受过失去他们、让他们切断与剧团联系的那种能量。这中间包含了很多感受。我想作为离开的那个人，某种程度上——我不知道。我把它想象成死亡，你看着它，你害怕它。然后你真正经历了它，其实并没有痛苦。它已经超出了你的控制。
Wendy Whelan, from a documentary called A Dancer Dies Twice , produced by Eleanor McDowall, originally a Falling Tree Production for BBC Radio 4. We have a link to the full half-hour documentary. I have to say, I usually hate documentaries where there's no narration. But this one is so, so good. It's at our website, thisamericanlife.org.
Wendy Whelan，来自纪录片《舞者之死》，Eleanor McDowall制作，原为Falling Tree Production为BBC电台4台制作。我们有那半小时纪录片的完整链接。我不得不说，我通常讨厌没有旁白的纪录片。但这一个太好了。请浏览我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。
Well, our program was produced today by Jonathan Menjivar. Our production staff includes Susan Burton, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Karen Duffin, Emmanuel Dzotsi, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, David Kestenbaum, Miki Meek, Robyn Smien, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Nancy Updike.
好了，我们节目今天由Jonathan Menjivar制作。我们的制作人员包括Susan Burton, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Karen Duffin, Emmanuel Dzotsi, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, David Kestenbaum, Miki Meek, Robyn Smien, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney 和 Nancy Updike。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our show's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he showed up at the office this week with a new haircut, kind of a retro one-- really tall, hi-top fade.
《美国生活》由公共广播交流协会PRX分发到各公共广播电台。一如既往感谢我们节目的联合创始人Torey Malatia先生。你知道，他这周来办公室换了个新发型，那种复古的——非常高，高耸的渐变头。
(AFRICAN ACCENT) Yeah, I've seen House Party. You know, this is one of my favorite movies.
（非洲口音）是啊，我看过《House Party》。你知道，这是我最喜欢的电影之一。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Ira Glass。下周将带回更多《美国生活》的故事。